tonight we are learning more about the
pilot of the plane that crashed
yesterday morning in the south part of
the valley that crash happened in the
area of valley view in pebble
the pilot took off from north las vegas
airport headed to san diego but wanted
to make an emergency landing at the
henderson airport
8 news now reporter kate houston has the
very latest on the investigation
this new video captured on a home
security camera shows the plane
descending
taking a nosedive and then crashing the
national transportation safety board is
leading this investigation
i reached out to the agency it says the
primary focus right now is collecting
information
and documenting the aircraft while no
official identification has been
confirmed
friends of the pilot are identifying him
as robert golo
the owner of air charter express the
business's website promotes air
transportation from san diego
los angeles and las vegas i've known him
for
close to 30 years robert arcy told our
sister station in san diego he just saw
golo last week
arcy says it must have been a mechanical
issue because golo took safety seriously
very cautious very conscientious careful
and safe the ntsb says it won't
determine the cause of the crash this
early in the investigation
the agency says it typically takes 12 to
24 months before a final report is
issued
a preliminary report will be available
in 10 to 12 days
kate houston 8 news now thank you and
the passenger in the plane crash has not
been identified yet